most fishermen on the banks of this
one's clean and flowing river are now
struggling to keep their livelihood
going no rahmet's family has fished in
the carnivale river for generations
there used to be an abundance of fish
here but over the years due to various
types of factory waste garbage and
polythene fish stocks are gradually
disappearing here
nowadays we barely get any fish aside
from some small shrimps it's hard for us
to manage a living anymore according to
a study bangladesh generates more than
800 000 tons of plastic waste a year
it's also reported to make up more than
60 of the leader found on the country's
beaches
and keeping the rivers clean is becoming
harder
we find various types of wastes like
polythenes plastics etc making it very
difficult for us to dredge and delays
our work
the chartergram port authority says it
recently found a layer of polythene up
to three meters thick while dredging the
riverbed
you can see thick layer of silt like
this at different points all across the
carnivale river here in chatogram pod
city this is due to years of dumping of
plastic polythene industrial and
household waste in the river
although bangladesh was the world's
first to ban plastic shopping bags due
to lack of enforcement and public
awareness polythene is still widely used
unless we manage to stop the production
usage and banning of polythene then at
some stage the kana fully river the
lifeline of chattagram will be totally
clogged the operation of the port will
be at stake
according to industry insiders there are
more than a thousand small plastic
recycling factories across the country
that produce plastic flakes from scraps
and some export them
we receive this from waste collectors
then we break them into microchips which
is later used once again to make plastic
products
but creating more plastic products isn't
helping tackle the problem
and the u.n says every day about 73 000
tons of plastic waste were entering the
bay of bengal through bangladesh some of
which comes from neighboring countries
in the aquatic ecosystem plastics
degraded into smaller sized
microplastics
that eventually enter into the food
chain
which is a big concern for food safety
and human health
environmental experts want the gradual
accumulation of pollution in the bay of
bengal may not only further threaten
fishing communities but also hamper
shipping and maritime trade chanwi
chaudhary jazeera choctawgram bangladesh